that's probably feeling like down there
forty sixty thousand dollars on running
cars just running renting just because i
don't know license nobody wants me to
drive i'm not the driver you don't want
roots to drive at all that's how i am i
drive with two feet that's all right
yeah so and i was just raising cars
doing superstars i was like that for a
while where i would just uh i didn't
have a car for a while and i would just
rent a car for a month and just pay like
whatever
yeah i need to give me like a black
just get a lease and then you could
write off a big part of the lease
because uh just connect it to your llc
or to your music something i can't drive
i don't know you don't have a license
never had a license never went to go get
one
my stepdad when i was like growing up he
was always like let me just
just whip
yeah so i got to get your license man
you're a grown up i never bro
i just that [ __ ] nothing is driving me
to get my license
it's a probably a shitty dmv line
you could probably set that up i can't
sit in the front you got to get your
[ __ ] license i gotta go somewhere far
now dave to go to a [ __ ] dmv look at
the d go get your license and bomb deal
or something
they know me and palmdale bro i can't be
in palmdale like that yeah go the
[ __ ] hammock
hey man
temecula they know me in temecula but
temecula's nice
you're right it's a lot of old people
out there who love wine all right i'm
gonna figure it out bro but i could see
they probably feel like i drive with two
feet i don't think they don't matter
like all grown-ups need their driver's
license i got my id [ __ ] i just got
my id
you just got an id so what were you
doing before that pulling out your birth
certificate no
just
telling them how the [ __ ] were you going
across the border to see your pops oh i
had
like that was like you know what i'm
saying i had a birth certificate but
even that [ __ ] was i would get double
checked yeah passport no
oh yeah man
yeah you know it's crazy [ __ ] i i had a
pat i mean
first they gave me i when i had got id
right they put that my birthday was in
like 1999 or some weird [ __ ]
i just sent back my id
so when i got a passport the last time
they put that my birthday was in 99
again
so i had to send that [ __ ] back and i
still ain't got your passport yeah yeah
good luck that [ __ ] takes forever yeah
bro you know what's so crazy i think
it's somebody else with the same name as
me and a birthday in 99.
cause they keep waiting
94. okay good year
young man doggy style you're the dog